yeah welcome to this video playing game
wiki kids have to check this Maxim
Lockhart okay do we get some Vienna game
yeah this line of this slider this is
not good but it's always still have to
remember why it is not good should be
five
yeah okay I'm blinking first don't don't
try to remember how to how to play it
best and just play normal moves probably
yeah I'm just being okay that says it's
good enough don't go for refutation and
ok show me
what is your big point
it just drops the exchange I don't see
any point at all and maybe six or
something like that but you can probably
take with the Queen then yeah so be sure
to q1 check okay so how to play here
maybe look g84 or just a 16 shouldn't be
bad ask the bishop about is further
plans would like to get the e5 pawn that
pawn is always a bit annoying bishop can
come to f3 yeah maybe this move for
clocking see a check just get out of out
of that d file
yeah okay if I go King c18 my txt six I
just got 94 so I'm going I'm going back
it's not a big issue okay that hangs
King be 79 f 5 foot well
just going to prevent night f5 what is
my idea here rook h2 eh maybe then f6
then e 6 Bishop d6 Wow
always had the vague idea that my porn
at seven could be weakness and now he
just just um you know allows me to get
rid of it the I can take c7 but I didn't
think that this is such a big problem on
any any problem let's uncle here so it's
not threatening a check or something ok
so where to put it a true cool f5
something like that
he actually gets here's two points for
the exchange I didn't really recognize
that up until now take a look T 1 okay
when there's a check is leading anywhere
probably not
so chick leading to something like night
white forfeits due to disconnection okay
yeah I know it's still probably good for
me very strange game GM yeah anyway this
is some Vienna and night when you three
isn't great but I'm not just quite sure
after Bishop if I don't think after
Bishop b5 I don't have something great
probably okay i just decided to keep it
simple and develop here 27 an hour-long
castle there it just doesn't work just
doesn't work yeah this is also
advantageous to that line you know TM
check we can try to hang on it's got a
its got a porn and i'm not super well
coordinated so it's not winning for
black budget is son yeah not a not a
good opening result of course this no he
i just i think i think i have to well i
don't have to go back if you take g 7i
have rook g8 so probably something like
that is in order no ok this happened a
g6 oops yeah i just wanted to make sure
that this night is not coming engine
doesn't like it wants to go who get hate
yeah okay but i just want to see you in
the distance cannot be terribly bad oh I
forgot I forgot something laughs more
huh I forgot this and I'm picking up a
piece i forgot that g5 is not covered
anymore so we couldn't even get the pawn
that porn back
yeah before it's just a bad move I mean
if he goes here and something like this
I mean he's got two pawns this should be
kind of okay for white and this is a bad
idea I mean here he has he has to give
up this poor man before or worse in his
pawn structure even though i don't know
the disconnection might have been just
what it was some kind of technical error
but it wasn't necessary here to let's
say resign by this connection i mean why
does not not losing here Knight f3 for
example is kind of kind of useful you
can take check do something like that
this is equal probably yeah I know maybe
a little something from for black but
it's not much the engine gets black a
small advantage something like this at
this probably because of the activity
and whites slightly problematic King
yeah it looks kind of problematic
actually but nothing I mean absolutely
nothing that would prompt you to resign
the game okay well thanks for watching